hello and welcome to this video this is
a video of the first video in fact in
our little serious here for reddit
opening of the week beating or playing
beating is a bit optimistic but it will
happen sometimes playing against offbeat
openings for white yeah offbeat
meaning those rambles like b4 ha g4 b3
Knight c3 and so on in this video we'll
be talking about the move one before
then so called so-called skier opening
sometimes also called the Polish opening
one the most colorful name would be the
orangutan which probably mispronounced
Germany it sounds totally different so
in German it sounds totally different
yeah one before and with all those rare
moves we can ask ourselves how bad is it
really well before isn't great but it
also not it's not disastrous for white
white weakens the queenside quite a bit
with before and doesn't really help that
much in development a positive side of
one before is that when it's Avery
something that at least is not going
wrong for widest the King safety yeah I
most like F form weakened the King or G
form
weaken the King which before doesn't so
if like is playing system some kind of
normal set up he will probably be
equalizing but nothing much more um
there are a couple of good replies
anything kind of healthy would work but
my recommendation is quite clearly the
movie 5 even if you are not a 1 V 4
player I would still strongly advise to
play that move because it leads to the
most fluent piece plane and in many
cases white will have real difficulties
out of the opening if he is not very
precise also it's important against all
of those rare lines
to play something that is easy to
remember because well you never get them
on the board or close to never I think I
never faced the move one before in
tournament chess at once sorry
once exactly once which is 20 25 years
ago or something like that so it's rare
and you should have something maybe look
at something once like this video
yes let's have some brief idea what to
do and then just go for that don't very
much about details that you will really
need any way it usually continues with
Bishop b2 and y2 text upon sometimes
while players try to just protect before
it is hanging after all after which um
yeah black just can occupy the center
with d5 yeah like we should be to Bishop
d6 and the general setup is Knight to f6
Queen d7 castles possibly c6 something
like that you don't need much more if
you take the sent and you have him yeah
why does not worse let's say but but
close to it yeah like it's got the
center and what is why I have this
should be true it's by far the more
common move and they can also go b5 by
the way but this is taking yeah
neglecting the center a bit to the
extreme
so Bishop b2 seems the most sensible
move the black has also tried a couple
of moves even some very unnatural stuff
like f6 folks I'm gonna move that I
don't understand at all I mean I do
understand the idea yeah you cover it
cover this and take here but I really
see a no point in wasting time with
weakening moves like that just develop
stuff Bishop takes before it develops
the bishop we take a pawn yeah why does
some basically force to take on e5 here
some people have tried f4 really wacky
but it has some points there for example
black shouldn't take as Bishop g7 Queen
h4 this
nothing is an awful mess and it's not
clear at all surprisingly at all yeah so
after f4 just go t6 cover that porn and
develop next if white is taking this for
example you just develop just similar to
the main line action it's just that the
D file is open deep one is exchanged for
f-pawn which is pretty terrible for
white I mean what about this King so f
was reassure so white takes only five
and this is the typical structure that
you get you have traded Epona against
people which you might think is not so
bad for white and flank pawn again sent
upon but the open D file the half open D
file is actually yeah it gives blacks
Tempe and very nice development Knight
f6 of course and here white has some
played a couple of moves but they mostly
lead to the same thing white plays
Knight f3
III and very often see for those moves
they kind of fit well together what
needs to develop the King side and c4 to
get some pawn in the center sometimes
white also voluntarily retreats back to
be to in one of the next moves so I'm
just going with one move order here but
it is pretty yeah there are there are
alternative ways to do things for
example white can start as we said like
with c4 like it's always doing the same
thing castling white plays whatever 9 f3
and you go rook e8 this is the thing to
remember castles
rook e8 and in the next couple of moose
here we go d5 and c5 if white plays the
move a3 black can I mean we have
alternatives but I always some felt like
ambition if 8 is not bad the bishop is
very safe there on evade and you still
go d5 a c5 words with much in 96 yeah
this is the thing just develop naturally
and quickly
let's as a mainline take the move on
III castles as we said Knight f3 rook e8
there is this the standard thing if we
are attacked we can go all the way back
to f8 or to u7 for that met assaults are
not bad to be honest I don't know much
more than that and whenever I get before
which is blitz games I have good
positions and I don't value so much but
it's good to know this setup is a little
bit more aggressive then let's say
anything based on one g5 or yeah
something something less ambitious let's
aim yeah so how does this continue here
we can look at a couple of moves some
some positions to get an idea what
happens this does not mean that you have
to learn all that stuff it just helps to
support yeah - it helps a little bit if
you get on the board to have seen things
beforehand but should be tuned for
example black board Cody 5 let's say C 4
for y to take the center and we go see
father always like to use that pawn to
fight for for the center but yeah let's
say cheek sticks castles 96 yeah it's no
big deal that this Bishop is out there
it looks at important squares it should
be to back and Bishop f5 for example
yeah Black has a very nice development
white has to Center pawns black has none
but note that the center is not mobile
at all and it rather looks like black is
going to centralize everything and puts
pressure on those Center pawns this is
the common problem of this opening that
black will get such a big quick
development that you cannot do much with
your Center here yeah it's it's not
going to yea rush forward and crush
black it's just mostly weakness
I'm pretty typical way how its how it
might turn progress um what else may
here why also can can castle and what do
we do
it's the same thing all over again just
c5 and white now it's not so easy you
cannot develop that night is the thing I
mean yeah theoretically you can but is
that a good position after Knight bTW
cell this is this is out there yeah
Bishop g3 like and even think of taking
and I play against to be pawns so it
doesn't quite add up
usually wide returns here and then again
96 let's say d3 yeah so just simple
simple moves 9 PT 2 and possibility for
this is something to consider
careful leave it there you go black and
just do that I probably doesn't fit well
with Bishop f5 I was just putting those
moves out it's not like I looked up any
big game references here black is just
fine there are also some pretty
aggressive things on pretty drastic
things that can happen if Y does not
care not paying any attention we can
look at a couple of things so if we
start with c4
black goes again t5 you can also start
with this if you like but this is a
little bit more aggressive in a way
because we don't meet survived in all
cases um
yeah white ticks you know if white is
going back voluntarily for example black
can go for c5 again if he likes knight
c6 try to go for D form something that
we have seen earlier that kind of motive
it's just if you have seen this you will
easily work it out over the body don't
need to learn any precise moves so C 45
takes take
and yeah now probably its wisest for
Wyatt to just go back and we see that
the development here is excellent for
black yeah I mean we've got castle the
rookies on half-opened file those pieces
are aggressively posted and wide only
has two pieces our and his two moves
away from cancelling Bishop b2 as I said
it's the most the wisest choice there
are a couple of things that lose
straightaway for example move like
Knight c3 for example black as punishing
with rook takes e5 Wow yeah and this is
close to winning for black I mean why
can can do crazy things like this but
ultimately yeah it doesn't work like
it's safe no your knight is hanging and
blankets to pieces up for rook a pretty
simple tactic so Knight c3 is bad this
looks completely normal thing is it
loses again due to that and white has to
give that night up
if he goes f1 Knight takes is three
years a big disaster will be three
shakes and yeah white is completely
completely falling apart damn many ways
for what wrong
yeah something else that white can show
I have a couple of examples here to
check Bishop c4 it's also been tried
Bashir g4 this should be too and in this
position black can play non moves on 96
for example but you may also choose the
sacrifice check
King f2 and I can use a sacrifice this
and shoot for the check chat and it
seems that one looking very thin ice
it is just a draw if widest if white is
very careful but white can do so it's
not like it's it's easy for example if
white steps to g1 then Bishop h3 will
lead to a very dangerous attack like us
having this idea this is also hanging
yeah I mean very dangerous stuff but
black has sacrificed a rope yeah it's
it's not a direct we know anything it's
just very dangerous the drawing line is
teeny too even though black of course
can try to attack I mean in some in a
blitz game for example I mean you can
easily play this and then gamble with
that and the computer gives draws but we
flex position is just menacing yeah
specially in shorter time controls so
many young aggressive possibilities this
this idea of sacrificing on e3 is a very
common one that yeah then you can should
should keep in mind you know especially
in a sense shorter time controls
sometimes even if it does not work
objectively in it's super dangerous so
takes takes Bishop b2 this is probably
the relatively relatively safer's yeah
here black has a couple of good moves
for example you can just develop with 96
Bishop a5 the move c5 that setup then I
also had mentioned early as also
possible therefore 96 Bishop out and so
on
and the most aggressive move forever is
directly related to blacks superior
development and can shoot for Knight f4
that's an interesting way to play they
are trying to hinder white from further
developing and possibly jumping on the
d3 square not easy at all for white
handle not easy at all yeah what so can
wait to what they tried a lot is 95
after which black has a very promising
continuation 25 it's pretty strong black
is attacking this twice attacking g2 and
if why it takes I mean probably has to
know if he white like goes back and we
go here and we just have gotten those
aggressive Queen moves for free so takes
and black just recaptures yeah and the
e-file that looks pretty bad white has
to now block the e-file somehow as no I
mean something like this is not going to
work out after 96 you're just in too big
to big trouble note that this check it's
also pretty pretty nice but maybe you
can improve that right yeah black can
also check here by the way that's an
interesting idea because how is white
saving is Queen for example or something
like that we can happily check check
some crazy complications now you don't
need to learn this knowledge as there
are a couple of interesting create the
things that you can check out all over
the board but the tech is very very
dangerous just nice to maybe keep in
mind 94 Queen g5 and black has a has a
great attack 95 was mostly designed to
attack the night in covered e3 and not
the only move of course um a3 for
example is something this is something
to avoid them after Queen a4 there are
two pieces hanging but black can step
back to the six and maintain his
pressure yeah it's not this is not
terrible for white but he's under
pressure quite clearly
so Knight f4 is an aggressive choice but
as I mentioned there's nothing wrong
with playing c5 96 Bishop f5 just
develop things and use pieces against
them the central pawn sense that white
then white has yeah all in all 1b form
isn't particularly dangerous but it is
some something that black cannot refute
yeah it's not terrible like like one g4
for that one g4 is really terrible
well black will get an advantage with
good play this is not possible with one
before if white plays decent shares
after he has taken this Liberty let's
say if you to play one before however
there are a couple of options as we have
seen or a couple of things that might
happen to white if he is not very
circumspect afterwards yeah the
sacrifice only three they can be very
very dangerous but in general there's
nothing wrong as I said if black just
gets with with normal development
something like this for example
ninety-six castles
five this kind of thing this is what I
usually do if I don't see something
really great yeah sacrifice that
immediately catches my attention and
it's not like as I said you get it on
the board quite often that before it's
pretty rare so it doesn't make much
sense to to study any piece sacrifice
line whatever in much depth it's just
good to know that these ideas are there
and if you happen to get it on the board
then you can still take a couple of
minutes in a real classical time control
game and figure it out and in blitz just
develop or just second have fun I mean
those those two things it doesn't make
sense to invest much time there at home
okay I hope you enjoyed the first video
here how to play against one before
there are many ways but this is one way
I think that is easy to learn and in
many cases will give you a very good
game thanks for watching